as thousands of afghan refugees make a
new home in the u.s a small group of
military spouses began collecting
donated furniture and household items
for the families the group has grown
into a movement with more than a
thousand volunteers
turns out these military moms know a
thing or two about moving and creating a
community deborah alfaron introduces us
to the woman who started it all
i think we're going to stage some stuff
first if it looks like amy martin has
done this before it's because she has as
a military spouse and mom of two moving
comes every few years we have lots of
moving hacks
we all have our best tricks
since afghanistan's capital kabul fell
to the taliban in august she's been
helping afghan families move into new
apartments in northern virginia every
weekend this is the way to do it first
thought was what are they going to do
and what can i do it's our duty to be
there to help them martin signed up to
volunteer for one of the many
organizations helping to resettle
refugees then she started a facebook
group to collect furniture our group
grew from 25 to 300 in a day and now we
sit somewhere around 1100. unwittingly
martin started an army you can help with
that and it wasn't long before martin
realized setting up an apartment was
just the beginning two days later they
called and they said we're out of food i
never got my social security card my
daughter is sick i don't know where to
go the needs started coming one after
the next and we were problem solving
very much on the fly martin says the
case workers assigned to help the
families were overloaded she and a
handful of volunteers started working
the phones trying to make calm out of
chaos thank you true military style we
made a standard operating procedure
we made a manual put our brains together
what have you all figured out tens of
thousands of people from afghanistan
have come to the u.s since the taliban
took over
abdul hasib delawar his wife and three
children arrived here the same day kabul
fell
i can't express the feeling at that time
that i'm losing everything that i have
made for a long time for years my home
my family my job everything you know it
was very difficult at the time delaware
worked as an interpreter for an american
military contractor in afghanistan what
do you think it would be like if you
didn't have their help i can't think how
it would be
because we didn't know the
transportation we didn't know how we can
get the
apartment where to buy
groceries we couldn't bring anything
with us
martin and her team helped delaware
enroll his two sons in school and work
with him on his resume so he can get a
job he says the warm welcome from
martin's group gave him and his family
hope these people are such a great
people
they are helping though they didn't know
me before but i feel like i know them
for years
martin has turned the facebook group
into a non-profit called react dc
with thousands more afghans waiting in
limbo around the world and eventually
heading here to the u.s she says helping
isn't a sprint it's a marathon it's kind
of walk the walk moment i have two kids
and it's about what are you going to
show them what kind of life are you
going to show them are you just going to
tell them to be good people you know and
serve your community are you actually
going to go out and do it for cbs
mornings deborah alfarone alexandria
virginia
just remarkable what she's doing i mean
the families have absolutely nothing
when they get here and covet has made
things very complicated in terms of
furniture and other supplies yeah i love
that she is being the example for her
kids shouldn't we all be it's proactive
she said i had a walk the walk moment
yeah yeah we all talk to talk and we all
ask ourselves you know what what can i
do but i feel like if you can do
something just get up and do it i know
don't just talk about it we got a big
heart in this country i like when we see
people showing it off a little bit
absolutely right we appreciate it